depuis que vous avez commencé dans les années 90,
vous avez eu une si belle carrière depuis
lors qu'est-ce qui a vraiment
changé dans l'entreprise beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de choses je veux dire je pense que la capacité d'
attention des gens a beaucoup changé je  signifie que
ces nouveaux services de streaming la possibilité
d'accéder à n'importe quoi à tout moment le
fait que vous ayez du nouveau contenu
chaque jour enlève en quelque sorte le frisson
de vous savez attendre que vous sachiez qu'une
sorte d'image hollywoodienne géante sortira, je
ne le fais pas  savoir si cela va devenir un
fossile du passé ou non, nous espérons que ce
ne sera pas le cas, mais en même temps, cela
apporte également la possibilité de financer
de nouvelles idées incroyables, des cinéastes, une
diversité de narration que je pense
incroyablement excitante, je pense que certains
des  les histoires que j'ai essayé de développer
pendant quatre ans n'auraient jamais une
chance d'être financées ou racontées ou
montrées au monde des choses que les gens
que vous connaissez sont un pari financier
et maintenant avec ces nouveaux
services de streaming un  beaucoup de ces histoires que nous
n'aurions jamais qui n'auraient jamais la
quantité de qualité que
nous voyons, donc c'est excitant c'est
exactement ça, c'est juste cette richesse de
talent de l'écriture à la mise en scène,
c'est assez extraordinaire à regarder et
au  en même temps, vous savez
où l'expérience cinématographique atterrira
et ce qui est jetable,
je pense que le jetable serait la
vraie question en ce moment, je suis truqué tout
c'est mon plaisir et mr.  Schwartz je suis une
mère mais
j'ai ton fils non c'est mon stand de cascadeurs à double
falaise d'accord quel est le problème
partenaire c'est officiel le vieux copain a été
ton [ __ ] de mannequin Ric ne l'oublie pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu pouvais revenir en arrière  à n'importe quelle décennie dont
vous vous êtes jamais soucié, pourquoi
reviendriez-vous à cette décennie au
cours du siècle dernier ou tout au long du
siècle dernier oh ça aurait été cool
ouais même si nous aurions été
debout dans le magma aurait été cool
pour voir la création de la zone ouais
quelle période quelle décennie à moins que
je n'aie pas tu vas avoir une bonne réponse
eh bien je dois dire qu'une des choses est
chaque fois que je regarde des films qui se déroulent
réellement à Hollywood en 63 ou 64
vous savez que nous sommes Dino's est sur le Sunset
Strip et les gens vivent à Larchmont
Village et conduisent et vous savez
et il y avait un peu comme une voiture de
sport décapotable vous savez que tout
Hollywood Boulevard Sunset Strip
surtout à cette époque qui semble ju  st
chic et cool comme l'enfer et je jure qu'il le fera
nous slat boy ça ne me dérangerait pas d'être moi
ouais je dois être moi et je veux avoir
ce que j'ai maintenant mais ayez-le que
j'aimerais refaire les années 90 mm-hmm  peut-être obtenir
un autre coup dans les années 1920 Oh les années soixante pour
moi ouais moi aussi les années 20 pas les années 60 Je dirais 20
dans les années 30 pour voir que j'aurais été
cool de voir l'ère du cinéma muet été
intéressante où j'étais comme le
Far West sauvage et Murph  pas de règles et c'était
un chahut absolu qui a l'air cool Je
veux juste que je regarde littéralement deux films
sur la réalisation de films dans les
jours silencieux J'ai regardé un Peter Bogdanovich juste
Nickelodeon et il y a un
film russe vraiment intéressant sur le même
sujet - par nikita mikela  la toux a appelé
un esclave de l'amour et ils sont tous les deux à peu près
les mêmes à propos de celui que vous connaissez
comme peu c'est assez intéressant
c'était assez intéressant
vous